[Music]
so in WTF news slaughter 5 Wednesday
Thursday Friday submitted by de Menace
with a deep domain Menace an elderly
woman is body slammed to the ground and
hurled into a swimming pool after she
asked them teens could turn down the
music I saw this [ __ ] and this video is
pretty [ __ ] terrible like this kid is
so [ __ ] dumb to the point where let's
just say he had a chance to stop and he
followed through the whole [ __ ] thing
that kids a [ __ ] dumbass the title
sounded like he was going to be funny
but ha ha ha ha what part of the title
is the grandma was cool I just had a
really funny image like one of those
cool grandpa's or something yeah but it
doesn't matter how cool someone is I
don't think they like me tell ya have
you ever watched don't be a menace and
something's on the wall sniffing
something's just over here fighting did
you I've ever seen that one scene with
the grandmas were breakdance battle you
know yes I had average I definitely not
getting bodies I'd also say grandmas
they were dudes dresser those grandmas I
apologize okay so how does this guy 16 1
16 it makes a little bit more sense now
yeah and a woman student 68 years old oh
my god but 16 is should know better -
you have like a lot of common sense in
you already like I'm saying like once
you see that [ __ ] you'll see like how
many times he had a chance to stop just
kept on going this is just his undoing
or less his own Julie pumped up I did it
as hard as people were cheering and
laughing a [ __ ] ass like who was
better witness it they should be just as
much trouble as this kid - because
that's [ __ ] ridiculous because even
when I was 16 I was doing a lot of
stupid [ __ ] it never crossed my mind to
bodyslam an old person yeah and I'm
guarantee you these kids didn't do half
of the batches that I did so it's like I
don't understand how that works out when
I was 16 I saw his dude screaming at his
wife and the wife's was crying like
crazy on the street and I stepped up to
the dude to telling to stop doing that
well so I was going to [ __ ] his ass
stuff and I opened the trunk
my 2,095 Honda Civic I pulled out a
baseball bat by uh every other Asian
would see this one same like I brushed
my bangs to the side yeah and I said
don't you dare do that again I put mine
over my undercut real quick flip my
visor upside down
because it's like a certain sense of
morality no matter how whatever you did
here's a video
Oh No please like this order by the way
looking always Florida oh is that heat
dude it makes you go crazy that one
orgasm ready are you young right a
Broward County teenager is facing some
incredible charges this morning he's
accused of assaulting a 68 year old
woman I'm here and throwing her into a
pool Broward ever you say he did it
because she was complaining about a
party being too loud oh my oh he could
already stop just went through there
Jones was just asking these kids to turn
down the music
that's when a young man decided he was
going to throw her into the pool which
seems like it would be a harmless prank
oh well with her to the ground she's not
my girl in any way whatever happened
just happened that day I don't know you
know keep kids that crazy a little bit
Reds were at that party and say they
didn't actually see her get thrown in
but did see the aftermath go too early
so I went out the gate and I went back
to see what happening I feel like she
came out to push you away and we showed
that video to neighbors they were blown
away she's an elder you need to show
respect for your elders that's crazy as
a horrible horrible thing that happened
to her Tracy and Simon Says Nancy was
the first person she met at players
place down home and that she can't
believe someone would do something like
this young people need to learn from
this and pay attention to what they do
and think about their actions before
they do them was that a dog who died or
very cool Ron and I give it you drag the
dogs into the pool no they were able to
get away because it's battery on a
person 65 years or older
Wow they should charge that as
a sense of murder or something because
when they're old like anything like
elected turned himself in I did yeah
okay thank goodness but at the same time
I feel like he turned himself in because
I didn't have a choice
it's not because he didn't all over the
Internet exactly like email a [ __ ]
choice so maybe his parents made him do
it
yeah what a piece of [ __ ] I don't know
if you guys heard right before he grabs
her a girl says yes all right
yeah nice being told people then getting
egged on to do that [ __ ] yeah I don't
know what's worse him or like the people
that kind of laughing and cracking the
[ __ ] up and it was going on and him is
definitely worse with pieces of [ __ ]
they should bring back lashings the good
part is we're not the good part but the
fall he hit he hit first in the she
bounced a little so you got the brunt to
end of that you know what that was too
silly
no you it both kind of hit it hard but
he got hurt so he's there and the sad
thing is like I already know what
happened in that [ __ ] kid's head is
that he slipped and he looked like a
fish exactly he had to commit all the
way through so he didn't look stupid
yeah also I was gonna clown on him yeah
what would have been tight is she turned
out to be like the MMA instructor and
she armbar the [ __ ] in the pool and beat
the [ __ ] out or not have been tight yeah
I would have been tight is she in Jersey
did a same a few injuries which were
bruises on her legs and shoulders I mean
she got a pretty low too by the way okay
no reports about her head I think she's
okay she looks super calm - she's not -
like can you keep it down and you just
[ __ ] throw her in the pool like man
dude that's not going to help anything
else she recently had hip surgery Oh No
does she have a husband or a son I can
go and beat the [ __ ] out of that dude
I'm not sure she did maybe they would
have gone to go tell the party that
showed us I'm pretty sure - maybe she's
just home alone yeah it's [ __ ] so
the sheriff's deputy also said that she
had her cell phone and her key fob in
her pocket when she went to the water
which
damage so that kind of sucks too on top
of everything else
Tanis may identify who the the people
were they're saying that already because
they should be this is Nancy oh my god
no there's no or net even if she's a
[ __ ] and she would like always gave him
[ __ ] or whatever that's don't [ __ ] up
taking a physical is crossing the line
not how much of a [ __ ] yeah yeah she's
a really large bruise on her leg and in
the shoulder dude I'm telling you old
people heal slow too that's going to be
like that for like the month what
happened she just dragged yourself out
of the pool walk back up I don't know
hope somebody help her out yeah I'm not
sure either just know that the police
ended up arriving and they're just
reporting that she was really confused
as to what happened yeah because does it
make sense yeah we turn down the music
boom like doesn't make any sense she's
actually the director of board for the
town homes are so that's why she
approached them - oh my god - turn down
the music doesn't even tell them like
stop just turn it down we got that team
he did get charged with one count of
battery on a person 65 years of age or
older
except to live the more severe now
you've got a juvenile detention center
Dan this kid's 16 and already [ __ ] up
your life man if I can do that I think
I'll have to beat the living [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of them every day for like a
month straight just to make myself feel
better cuz it's like you have a mom yeah
I mean like imagine that your mom yeah
and then I'd also save the top of his
head and then superglue a walker to his
hands you want to [ __ ] with all people
you're going to be an old person 4:38
appreciate it yeah yeah but when he
turned himself in he apparently said I
messed up I have to own up to it
Yeah right expertise is in the hope it
came from him and not because he was
forced seems like it was worse what a
[ __ ] that douzo thing has the childhood
that port had are you afraid of your
child doing similar things and how would
you handle in the future well I
protected yeah well we like to you know
lady with Minnie Bart like with his kid
like I don't ever recall any stories of
anything this is special to people I'm
honorable um I'm mischievous but I'm
honorable because you know what because
the thing about it is she
no matter what in Asian culture there's
a respect of elder yep and that is like
the root of how you treat other people
like even for me even if older cream and
was [ __ ] disrespect I would still
have trouble raising my voice do because
I was taught to respect all the people
no matter what so that already that
foundation is already there United mean
so for me
oh [ __ ] like I can't wait you'll do that
to an old person yes if my son didn't
deny that definitely for it to take him
to juvie he [ __ ] his own life over and
then comes out your [ __ ] slave to
this person all like you [ __ ] me yeah
you could you have to be their Walker
you have to punch over me flip bars I'll
get basically the white lady to play
oh I'm saying my kid if you did that to
a person
I will turn down I'll make it like here
this lady flame will hold also get the
guard this is got those people we told
my situation if you [ __ ] up your good
service time in juvie if you must [ __ ]
up his own life that's fine but then I'm
saying you have to pay back whatever the
[ __ ] you did so whatever they need you
got to weigh on them hand foot and I was
clap my kid there's one of the lady like
10 times and the teacher kids Vantage
your kids not to be followers and
degenerates
cuz I guarantee if nobody was saying
door in and when I done it
he wasn't did it and and what you said
is exactly right he felt stupid for
falling and he was like she has to be
the one that stupid he's [ __ ]
searching for attention and [ __ ] just
get this yeah I wish kids would like
have more respect instead of like is
like no respecter Kingdom is dosa yeah
so more positive things out that be a
way that and like a boundary that
shouldn't be crossed and I seem so
blurred nowadays you know it means in
kids today I hear we all sounds old you
tear I don't care they they are crazy
right
all of them just [ __ ] crazy there is
also a reason why kids next
fit perfectly in the palm of adult hand
well if you just reach across and oh
thanks for watching just kidding news
guys don't forget to comment down below
we want to hear what you say only if
it's positive remember that to watch
more videos go up here baby